it has been more than two years since
nba superstar kobe bryant his 13 year
old daughter gianna and seven others
were killed in a helicopter crash now a
lawsuit filed by bryant's wedding widow
that's vanessa bryan has gone to trial
in los angeles she accuses police and
firefighters of sharing graphic photos
of the crash part of what her lawyer
told the court was a culture of
callousness
our national correspondent jerica duncan
has more on this story
years after l.a county officials took
pictures of victims remains in the hills
of calabasas california including kobe
bryant and his daughter gianna a trial
centered on law enforcement's conduct is
underway vanessa bryant was visibly
emotional during wednesday's proceedings
crying frequently in a dramatic opening
statement her attorney claimed law
enforcement exploited the accident by
taking and sharing pictures of kobe and
gianna as souvenirs
bryant's attorney also told jurors the
photos were virtual gossip and played
security video of an off-duty sheriff's
deputy showing them to a bartender to
support that claim an attorney for the
county said the footage marked a
regrettable moment of weakness and said
that site photography is an essential
tool for first responders to share
potentially life-saving information
though the sheriff previously admitted
that deputies had no place to take
photographs of bryant's remains brian's
lawsuit alleges the photos circulated
among 28 sheriff department devices and
at least a dozen firefighters but the
county's attorney defended leadership's
response pointing out that the photos
have never appeared publicly and calling
it a function of how diligent
authorities were at the time the sheriff
contained the photo spread by making
involved parties delete them rather than
conducting a formal investigation as a
result bryant's attorney claimed photos
could still be in circulation
bryant voiced that concern last year in
court documents writing for the rest of
my life one of two things will happen
either close up photos of my husbands
and daughters bodies will go viral
online or i will continue to live in
fear of that happening for cbs mornings
i'm jerica duncan
i hope those photos never become public
i like the i think it's interesting that
they said a regrettable moment of
weakness that doesn't make any sense to
me it doesn't doesn't make any sense
callousness exactly
that's what that is
and i think about vanessa and her family
now having to relive that as they're
sitting on in the courtroom
talking about this again especially in
the day and age where one leaked photo
can travel around the world just like
that